hi ben um i'd like to ask a question
about
identity politics sure so to establish
credibility i guess
i'm a little brown first generation
american uh immigrant and lgbt activist
i'm also conservative um
sorry to the person who gave the shout
out before that there was there's more
to the description it turns
out it's i believe we can be friends
with people we disagree with
um but as a result of this combination
of identities i've been called a bigot a
race traitor i've been mocked and all
this kind of stuff
which kind of led me to become a closet
conservative
so i'm my question to you is what advice
do you have for closet conservatives to
survive in a climate or an environment
like a college campus like this so that
i can get a's in my classes but also
voice my opinion on essays okay so i
have a i have a
thriving
first of all as you can see from the
people in the crowd
thank you for being somebody who doesn't
identify by your
by your identity groups but more
identifies by the things that you
believe i think that that's very
important
um beyond that the best way to get by so
i have a thriving debate with
my friend dennis prager on this so
dennis who hasn't been in college in a
while he thinks that you should just say
whatever you want you should say clearly
and publicly
in front of professors and if you get
the c you've stood up for principal and
i think this is silly
so what i have always suggested is that
the means must be tailored to
to meet the ends in class you're not
there to mouth off you're there to get
the a and move on to whatever grad
school you want to go to
right i mean that's what you're there
for and if you got and if you're writing
in blue books
anonymity provides you with a certain
amount of of
protection and what that means really is
that you can speak out as much as you
want many cases in the class and then if
you write the blue book
you can write what the teacher wants to
hear and get the a that was my plan at
ucla
so in class i was frederick hayek i was
milton friedman i was thomas sowell
and then my blue books that was bernie
sanders and
and it worked out great right i mean
like
and it's not immoral because the truth
is that the professors are not testing
you on your actual thoughts right the
professors
very often are testing you on how well
you pair it back to them their thoughts
and so all right fine if that's the game
then i can play the game but i'm not
going to sacrifice my future career and
earnings
simply to make a point to a professor
who's more than happy to lower my grade
in order to in order to punish me
so i think well practicality goes a long
way but you should speak out when you
can the question is when can you